il est près de neuf heures quand un
bruit effrayant tonnes dans la rue de
trévise le 12 janvier 2019 une onde de
choc qui se propage à travers paris et
qui laisse dégagé une fumée noire
impressionnante
les vieux démons d'une année 2015
tragique refont surface chez les
riverains
mais la crainte d'une attaque terroriste
est vite balayée il ya une grosse
explosion fait j'ai entendu un bruit
sourd et ça a explosé et est très vite
du de la rue qui ont explosé des
bâtiments et une boulangerie juste à
côté qui est parti en fumée
ça a cassé toute l'inde passage après
entendu des cris et les gens que c'est
pas un mec se demander ce n'était pas
un attentat pour quelque chose comme ça
et qu'on en est sorti il y avait toutes
les vitres étaient cassées
les gens qui te livrer
c'est vraiment fort j'ai jamais entendu
un bruit pareil et la jeune fille nous
sommes soufflés effondré limoges
voilà je me suis habillé je suis
militant d'une sortie contre les
policiers sont venus nous dire d'évacuer
les officiels se rendent rapidement sur
place et constatent l'étendue des dégâts
collatéraux engendrés par cette
explosion accidentelle due au gaz des
secours mobilisés durant tout le week
end
une enquête est immédiatement ouverte
les pompiers sous l'autorité du général
commandant de paris sont encore à la
manoeuvre pour tenter de sauver les
personnes qui sont encore sur site
nous avons les informations qu'il ya
encore des personnes sur site et donc
nous poursuivons nos interventions
voilà ce que je peux vous indiquer je ne
rentrerai pas dans les détails du bilan
humain il est lourd un lourd bilan
quatre personnes sont mortes dont deux
pompiers et une soixantaine de blessés
sont à déplorer
un drame qui fait également près de 400
sinistrés une longue bataille judiciaire
commence alors pour ces riverains
désemparés deux ans plus tard la mairie
de paris
les assurances collectives et
individuelles traîne encore des pieds
pour indemniser les victimes à hauteur
de leurs attentes